[Musique]
bien il ya ce premier jour du ce est ce
un petit jet lag qui pique un petit peu
il ya quoi là il ya neuf heures de
décalage horaire quotidien serbe va y
avoir plein plein plein plein de belles
choses à raconter sur crs
il ya plein de produits tous leurs
vraiment super plein de nouveautés je
pense qu'on va se marrer je peux pas
tout vous présenter dans une seule et
même vidéo parce qu'ils se rendent
demandent beaucoup tu auras beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup de nouveautés alors
aujourd'hui je vous fais un petit peu
leur cadre de ce qui va se passer
j'ai commencé ce matin par un rendez
vous avec sony à 10h30
[Musique]
et
pour cela un taux rapide du stand de
sony alors bon c'est beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup thé daily cite j'ai pas
forcément non détaillées il ya tout ce
qui va être cinéma de 70,1 tout cas
c'est marrant c'est un concept car alors
c'est pas une voiture qui va sortir sur
une voiture signé sony sony n'a pas dit
qu'il sortirait de voiture ils ont
produit que vous sentirez mal non plus
ce concept car est censée montrer le
meilleur des technologies sony tous à
intégrer dans un vécu
l'idée c'est de la sécurité l'idée c'est
aussi le voter divertissement jours ou
quelques images du véhicule
et puis moi
[Musique]
on vend aussi le varois ne plus qu'il ya
un concept possède deux smartphones
c'est le concept one ça ça va être
vraiment intéressant rendez-vous ensuite
avec lg à 15 heures ouais dans une zone
particulière en effet sur notre stand au
ces deux années je t'emmène au vent
restaurant gaulliste en mettre dans mon
pas n'importe lequel restaurant dans un
restaurant qui gérait 100% par des
robots petit groupe de presse go pro et
puis ce soir il ya un show stoppeur qui
vous présente plein d'entreprises
différentes on reçoit les mémoires c'est
vraiment cool
il ya une réception par amd regardez
cette machine de dingue avec les
ventilateurs comme ça et je sais pas
réellement à quoi ça sert je suis pas
spécialiste d'ailleurs voyez deux fois
dayan d'alpro ce rise and amd avec tout
le système de refroidissement et puis
ensuite j'ai un petit dîner des équipes
de samsung je pense qu'on va se régaler
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
laissez moi vous parler de concept one
qui est le concept de smartphone concept
de la pardonne plus alors je vous en
parlais lorsqu'ils ont annoncé ça
lorsque j'ai vu passer les trucs sur l
oublie ça il faut que j'en pense attendu
qui fâchent moins cool parce que c'est
pas un smartphone quoi pouvoir avoir
c'est un concept one en fait c'est plus
une technologie common qu'autre chose
on se positionne sur un envoi de plus
cet epr aux mclaren edition un
smartphone bien fini avec des veaux
matériaux comme ce qu'on a avec ce
smartphone notre partenariat entre
points de plus et mclaren mais la lidc
croit plus retenir que au niveau de la
caméra arrière et bien votre caméra
lorsque vous n'activer pas le mode
appareil photo votre caméra est
complètement invisible surtout que la
province de parwan plus c'est ça qui est
intéressant c'est à dire que vous avez
un mot du noir vous avez une partie
noire vous ne voyez pas là vous le voyez
si vous tournez légèrement si vous allez
chercher effectivement pour le mettre là
où il ya de la lumière
vous allez le deviner sur une espèce de
refluer mais lorsque vous avez face à
vous voyez victimes en un écran noir et
lorsque vous prenez votre smartphone
vous activer la caméra
là vous voyez les modules photo qui
apparaissent pour moi ce qu'il faut
comprendre c'est que vous avez deux
verres des verts qui font chacun 0,1
millimètre les deux ensemble ça vous
fait 0 35 mm vous me direz 01 plus dur
ça fait 0 2 n'est pas 0,35 il ya
peut-être de la colle de l'espace entre
je sais pas toujours ce qu'il a fait en
total 0,35 autant dire que cette aussi
faim tu portais son écran c'est vraiment
parce que la smart phones dans les mains
on n'a pas l'impression d'avoir un truc
un peu gronde a vraiment la sensation
d'avoir un truc tout fin ça change pas
en fait je vois absolument pas la
différence entre un smartphone de one
plus que 27 & prom a claironné dix
jeunes et ce modèle là le concept one
entre libre je vois pas qu'il ya une
nouvelle techno j'ai pas l'impression
qu'ils adhèrent qui est plus épais en
tout cas c'est complètement invisible et
l'idée justement c'est vous avez un des
verts qui va s'obscurcir c'est ce que
roanne plus appelle un verre
électrochrome dynamique ça va changer la
couleur du vert et en gros ça marrant le
trou invisible alors l'idée c'est
qu'aujourd'hui on l'a sur une petite
portion relevant au niveau de la caméra
mais vous pourriez avoir cette
technologie sur l'ensemble de votre
smartphone et faire changer
votre smartphone c'est complètement
possible dans s'est pas fait par mois de
plus sur ce smartphone on peut imaginer
quel avenir pour pourrait avoir des
d'eau qui vont changer de couleur et
pourquoi pas à voir la couleur que vous
souhaitez en fonction de vos goûts alors
bien évidemment ça serait un doux envers
il faut quand même le protégé par une
coque de protection en tout cas hâter
que je trouve vraiment intéressante et
elle fait très jolies promesses
là on a caché l'appareil photo passe
quelques années on avait quoi un module
photo le module photo nll trois modules
photo 3 c'est comme ça trois des quatre
modules photo on arrive à cinq mois des
photos on aura peut-être sept à l'avenir
donc on va voir des espèces de
smartphones avec des caméras de tous les
côtés ça n'a pas forcément être hyper
beau samedi quand on commence à être
intégrés donc là l'idée c'est que tu
dois dire ok on se pose plus la question
de l'intégration on veut juste bien
positionnés pour ça marche
d'un point de vue hardware et d'un poids
du software c'est l'idée de base mais ça
devient complètement transparent est
invisible pour l'utilisateur mais ça
c'est vraiment génial parce que ça
permet d'avoir des smartphones toujours
plus beau et on va plus se poser la
question de la voir le module par module
toy boy du foot là vous l'avez les
cacher vos activités qu'il apparaît et
disparaît c'est beau c'est pratique pour
avoir cet effet de changement
transparence ou en plus utilisent des
particules organiques et yann hautement
qui est vachement intéressant c'est que
ça crée un verre polarisant pour vous
protéger lorsqu'il ya beaucoup de
lumière en extérieur l'idée c'est que si
vous le savez si vous faites de la photo
de la vidéo mais lorsqu'à beaucoup
lumière d'un des fonds mais l'utilisent
pour la raison aux bulls un objectif que
je ne fais jamais et des fois je devrais
faire la peau coup ça vous en fait un
c'est plutôt bien le changement de
couleur se fait en 0.7 seconde au
tauriac c'est très rapide
personnellement je n'ai pas mesuré un
jeu reprend juste que nous dit wang plus
je les crois sur parole
bon je pense que l'idée est plutôt bonne
je pense que l'idéal est bien l'idéal
est là alors c'est effectivement pas un
produit grand public que vous allez
pouvoir avoir tout de suite mais en tout
cas ce que ça montre et ce qui est
vraiment génial c'est que on va
s'abstraire un peu de toutes ces
contraintes matérielles pour avoir un
produit qui devient de plus en plus
jolie
on va pouvoir imaginer plein de choses
plein de couleurs différentes de tous
les côtés et là je vous parle de
l'ariège qu'on ne puisse pas
effectivement de conseils de planquer la
caméra n'a rien on peut imaginer ça pour
dire aussi de planquer la caméra l'avant
vous savez c'est un des enjeux sur 2020
je pense que ça va arriver c'est l'effet
d'avant des écrans sans encoches sans
bulles sans doute sans rien vous allez
voir votre caméra qui est planqué sous
l'écran je pense qu'on va aussi arriver
là dessus grâce à ce genre techno son
sac poule jeu ça vraiment intéressant
tout ça parce que ça montre plus c'est
que renault était toujours là pour
innover en connaît même plus penser que
c'est des smartphones haut de gamme à un
prix défiant toute concurrence avec des
supers technologies
écran 90 enfin je vous passe la complète
vous renvoie si vous ne savez pas mais
dernières vidéos sans les one plus l'été
one piece est des pros et compagnie vous
verrez c'est vraiment bien mais surtout
ce que ça montre c'est l'innovation
d'entreprise linehan déjà ils sont
surpris rennes plus sortant de
smartphones one + 7
one piece est propre en plus sept
témoins de +7 des pros le macarena des
chiens qui étaient déjà là au nouveau
duo en plus systémique l'edition bon ça
je vous passe un peu l'histoire mais
l'idée c'est de voir que cette boîte
continua complètement innover et se
montre à la pointe de l'innovation là
dessus moi je trouve ça vraiment hyper
cool et ça promet une année 2010 qui va
être vraiment excitante est vraiment
hyper hyper intéressante alors à savoir
si loin de plus va l'intégrer
directement en 2020 à interpol peut-être
peut-être pas je pense je pense sans me
tromper qu'en 2020 one piece a continué
de nous surprendre nous ont déjà son
prix l'année dernière avec deux
smartphones différents je ne pense
qu'aux 2020 pour moi franchement surpris
par la marque et d'ailleurs je vous
invite à me dire ce que vous en pensez
en bas en commentaire qu'est ce que vous
pensez cette technologie est ce que tu
as trouvé intéressante
est-ce que vous pensez que c'est
vraiment bien pour venir blanc qui
toutes ces caméras l'arrière et est ce
que vous pensez surtout c'est la bonne
façon de faire parce que moi tout ça en
bas en commentaire
[Musique]